all right we have made more progress in
the last 24 hours with new information
and breaking news tonight I'm going to
go through all of this very very slowly
the media has been lying to you
they have been entirely wrong for almost
a year and that relates to the real
Russia story you do not want to miss a
minute of tonight's program tonight we
will prove how we've been right all
along and ahead of the curve and how
wrong they have been we will lay it all
out all of the ugly details and there's
a ton of new information tonight we have
explosive information on the mass of
uranium one scandal that the Obama
administration attempted to cover-up we
have been telling you for years this was
going to be a big deal and tonight it is
now the hills John Solomon is out
tonight with another absolutely stunning
report here's the headline Obama
administration granted a visa entry to
Russian nuclear executive under FBI
investigation for bribery now according
to this new report the Obama
administration actually granted a
temporary work visa to this top Russian
official in 2011 then they renewed it in
2014 even after there was overwhelming
evidence this official was involved in a
criminal scheme that involved
racketeering bribery extortion money
laundering also tonight Fox News is
learning that senior Justice Department
officials are finally deliberating over
allowing the FBI informant - now testify
and tell the truth before Congress this
informant is the key player in the
latest developments that we have been
sharing with you on this uranium one
scandal and as John Solomon and Sarah
Carter have reported the informant
helped uncover a Russian nuclear bribery
as I said bribery kickbacks extortion
money laundering criminal enterprise
which began one year before the approval
of the uranium one deal before it was
approved now of course all of this
evident was evidence was kept secret
from Congress by the Obama
administration on purpose now because
this iWitness signed a nondisclosure
agreement that prevented him from
telling Congress and the American people
the truth now in addition to all of this
the hill and circuit news are reporting
that the same FBI informant
also has evidence of Russians trying to
influence the Clinton specifically this
is on top of what we already know about
the Clintons role in uranium one the
hills reporting that Bill Clinton tried
to get State Department permission
remember his wife was running this to
meet with a Russian nuclear official
while the uranium one deal was actually
being approved by the Obama
administration and we can't forget yet
just before the deal what did Bill get
he pocketed a half a million dollars in
a speech from Moscow that was double his
normal speaking fee and during that
meeting he was advocating for uranium 1
and he sat down with Vladimir Putin now
one I had one other point here and this
is important you want to talk about a
real Russian conspiracy listen to this
the bank that was paying Bill Clinton
when you pay attention to this that Bank
was connected to Putin and that bank
also had financial interests in uranium
1 and there's more according to a hill
report published last night after
Hillary Clinton became the Secretary of
State Russian spies purposely tried to
gain access to Hillary her top aides and
the former President Bill Clinton now
the report notes that one Russian spy
who was successful actually got a job
with a major Democratic donor and
actually was arrested and deported
now there's Peter Schweitzer's book
remember Clinton cash who the first to
bring that to your attention it exposed
how a hundred and forty five million
dollars in donations poured into the
Clinton Foundation while Hillary was
Secretary of State while she was
approving the uranium one deal now this
is what people all across this country
and all of you corrupt people in the
media you should all be angry about this
tonight now because of all of the
evidence of wrongdoing earlier today
finally finally prayers answered
House Republicans announced that key
committees will finally be launching
investigations into this corrupt bribery
uranium one kickback deal take a look we
do have a witness who was a confidential
informant who wants to talk about his
role in this and we're in contact with
the Justice Department to release him
from
disclosure agreement if that doesn't
work out in timely fashion and we
obviously would be able to subpoena em
you know on the Oversight Committee
particularly my subcommittee for me
focusing on how the interagency process
worked in this seven years ago in fact
seven years ago this month I raised
these objections with the Treasury
secretary who said they were being fully
investigated and obviously we want to
see what happened to that inquiry what
information was reports their attention
what they knew then why they acted or
didn't act and put it in context of
what's come out since then our job here
is to get the facts where the
legislative branch of government and we
will do just that here's my prediction
tonight people will be going to jail
over this now this is something we've
been calling for for weeks months even
over a year the house is also launching
an investigation into how the Obama
Department of Justice how the FBI
handled Hillary Clinton's email server
case and I've got to say it's about time
because the evidence of wrongdoing in
both of these massive scandals is
overwhelming it's incontrovertible and
it put our security at risk and as we
have been saying for months Congress has
a duty a moral obligation we can't have
a dual justice system they must
investigate these scandals fully and
they must uncover the truth of what
actually happened how is it possible how
that they never recognized that giving
Vladimir Putin and the Russians 20% of
our uranium the foundational material to
nuclear weapons a hostile actor is a
good idea and with uranium 1 Congress
literally can start by calling on key
Obama administration officials Eric
Holder rod Rosenstein and yes Robert
Muller I hope you're watching you need
to testify under oath and let me tell
you why as the Attorney General Eric
Holder of course he had oversight over
the FBI he was a member of the
government committee that actually
approved uranium 1 but yet they had all
this evidence of corruption and bribery
he clearly had the information then
there's now Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein well he was actually in
charge of this FBI investigation into
this Russian bribery and money
laundering scandal and finally Special
Counsel Robert Muller back in 2009 he
was the FBI director
this is when the bureau the FBI so
clearly had this information he has
complex of interests there's no way the
American people can trust robert muller
to investigate anything russian related
to be fair and impartial it's impossible
because of his past role in this he
should resign immediately tonight now
also the house tonight is also going to
be investigating the Obama Department of
Justice and the FBI's handling of the
Clinton email server scandal all
happening tonight now aside from Clinton
having secret top-secret special access
program classified information
mishandled the felony on her server
remember the one stored in a in the
bathroom of a mom-and-pop shop the house
will be looking into the former FBI
director which they should James Comey
and is inexcusable conduct now you may
remember he drafted the letter
exonerating Hillary Clinton before ever
conducting the interviews with the key
witnesses including Hillary Clinton
herself call me also he abused his power
when he announced he was not
recommending charges against Clinton he
never had that authority and we've got
the Attorney General former attorney
general Loretta Lynch remember the
tarmac meeting with Bill Clinton days
before commis decision and like we've
been saying it's about time these are
all serious issues all need to be
investigated fully and those involved
need to be held accountable we're also
learning tonight that we were right
about the GPS fusion dossier tonight
even the Washington Post has to finally
begin to report what we have been
telling you forever and according to the
Washington Post tonight I'd love to
quote them Hillary Clinton's campaign
and the DNC they paid for that phony
research that eventually became the
dossier that's the same document that
used Russian government paid sources and
made wild and completely untrue and
ridiculous accusations about Donald
Trump and remember the Democrats media
they were happy to repeat for example oh
that Donald Trump was in the Ritz
in Moscow and he had hookers urinating
in his bed and James Comey wanted to
hire this man in
in taxpayer dollars all of this makes
the Clinton campaign and the DNC tonight
complicit in spreading Russian
propaganda and Russian lies about then
candidate Donald Trump now they're
spreading this Russia propaganda
they've been lying to you the American
people using phony Russian sources and
this lies gone on for over a year this
is real Russia collusion this is the
real Russia story Robert Muller wake up
tonight now Fox News has also confirmed
the information in the Post article is
correct in other words we've been right
for over a year and we want to point out
another part of the Washington Post
article it reads quote fusion gps's
research into Trump was funded by an
unknown Republican client during the GOP
primary this is before the DNC and
Hillary Clinton's campaign took over
okay I want to know who is that was it
was it one of the other candidates was
it Senator McCain who reportedly gave it
to the FBI who's behind this we need
answers
keep in mind it was McCain he said he
passed this dossier around and by the
way we have to wonder if this new
information is the reason why the group
behind the dossier Fuzion GPS is trying
to stop lawmakers from accessing their
bank records hmm follow the money
now the entire Democratic apparatus most
of the Republican apparatus and all of
the mainstream media they fell hook line
and sinker for a Russian disinformation
lying campaign to the American people
during an election the Democrats Hillary
Clinton they all lied to you for over a
year now keep in mind there is a report
James Comey he tried to pay Christopher
Steele the former British spy who put
this whole dossier together he wanted to
give him your money
and tonight predictably the new DNC
chairman Tom Perez he's I didn't do this
he's denying in any personal involvement
with the dossier you're gonna hear a lot
more of those denials in the days to
come
we'll continue to follow that story also
tonight very important report and that
is pathetic weak gutless spineless never
Trump or establishment Republican forces
all lashing out against the president
today
now senators bob Corker we have little
snowflake whiny Jeff Flake and John
McCain all bashing the president instead
of doing what focusing on passing tax
reform for the Forgotten men and women
and poverty on food stamps and out of
work in this country take a look
was one of those that hope that you know
he would rise to the occasion as
president and he is not risen occasion
it's very evident to me it's obvious his
his political model and governing model
is to divide you know it's a sad place
from my perspective for our nation and I
think that the worst it is gonna be just
the whole the basing if you will of our
nation we must stop pretending that the
degradation of our politics and the
conduct of some in our executive branch
are normal
reckless outrageous and undignified
behavior has become excused and
countenanced as telling it like it is
the notion that we shouldn't say or do
nothing in the face of such mercurial
behavior is a historic and I believe
profoundly misguided to announce that
there must be no criticism of the
President or that we are to stand by a
president right or wrong is not only
unpatriotic and servile but is morally
treasonable to the American public when
the flight service to this country in
this Senate is reviewed it will be of
one of Honor of brilliance and
patriotism and love of country here's a
simple truth all three of these guys
they're inept they're ineffective they
have completely failed to deliver on the
promises that they made to their
constituents and you the American people
for years these guys have accomplished
nothing and others like Ben Sasse too
and you know what all they're doing here
is standing in the way of enacting an
agenda to help move the country forward
what the people voted for last November
and they're trying to be martyrs in the
process you want to be martyrs you guys
go right ahead
here's my answer to all of you tonight
good riddance Happy Trails don't let the
door hit you on the way out of town
now before his little stunt on the
Senate floor senator flake announced he
wasn't going to be running for
re-election in 2018
now here's part of the truth here flake
is now trying to say his decision is all
about President Trump but here's the
truth because he lied today at least
he's not choosing to run again because
back in August flake had an 18% approval
rating among voters in Arizona and
another poll showed that he was losing
to his chief Republican primary
challenger dr. Kelly Ward who would have
crushed for flake in a primary had he
had the courage to run and then he got
bob Corker he's done nothing but
attacked the president now for weeks bob
Corker he's stepping aside he's not
running again because he would have lost
in Tennessee so I have a suggestion for
all you never Trump or senators that are
headed for the exits people like corker
and flake you know what guess what you
guys you know take your other colleagues
with you Mitch McConnell goodbye Ben
Sasse goodbye John Cornyn goodbye Lisa
Murkowski Susan Collins either get the
job done that you promised the American
people advance the President's agenda
what are the conservative values that
the president is advocating for that you
are unwilling to support many of you can
retire and we'll all be happier now the
difference here between President Trump
and these senators that I just listed is
the president is a fighter he's fighting
for what he believes in I like somebody
fighting for the American people and
he's also somebody that is keeping his
word as promises the Senate has done
next to nothing to help the president
keep his promises or help the American
people or help the Forgotten men in
poverty on food stamps and out of work
look at these statistics the Senate has
confirmed in about a year since January
only 175 a president Trump civilian
nominees guess what
229 have yet to be confirmed
how many vacations of these guys take
and during a similar time frame
President Obama had 359 nominees
confirmed over twice as much and listen
to this through September of this year
the House of Representatives and I have
disagreements with them at times at
least they do their job they have passed
308 bills that
in that chamber and of those 308 bills
that the House of Representative passed
the Senate has passed 34 beyond an
embarrassment beyond a disgrace these
guys are the definition of failure the
poster children of failure Senate
Republicans are no longer serving the
American people so you know what senator
flake by you know what senator corker
see you later
it's time for accountability it's time
to drain the swamp if Republicans don't
back this agenda a tax reform repealing
and replacing they need to get out of
the way or resign or retire or do
something because you know what the only
reason these people are now saying
they're not running is because they
can't win and for all you never Trump
pers who are watching tonight take a
look at the side of your screen they
happen to be Donald Trump's
accomplishments let's see pretty long
list real tangible accomplishments
promises made promises kept so what have
you never Trump has done in this period
of time have you helped the millions of
Forgotten men and women in this country
that are suffering well the answers are
simple you've done nothing other than
help the Democrats obstruct the
president at every single turn and you
know what enough said enough